kansas city i can't wait to get to your
wonderful town i'll be there january
20th through the 22nd get your tickets
for those dates and all dates at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media night pants nation tour
headed to kansas city this weekend
thursday to saturday uh vancouver i'll
be there february 17th to the 19th go to
ryancicler.com for all your tickets uh
and if you're watching on youtube please
subscribe i say every week it does
nothing for you and everything for us so
if you're watching hit that subscribe we
appreciate it patreon man
the stories we continue to get i i we
just did a patreon episode with a girl
who was um
a sperm donor uh baby she was a sperm
donor baby she said test tube baby
whatever you want to call them um and
what she found out is she's potentially
one of like 500 [ __ ] kids and
just since we've released that episode
uh in the threads she's already
connected with other brothers and
sisters it's crazy so it's five bucks a
month um you get the honeydew a day
early ad free at no additional cost if
you sign up for a year you're getting
over a month free all right uh if you or
someone you know that has that story it
has to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com hopefully we
get to do an episode together all right
um look you know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers i'm very excited to have
this storyteller on today here for the
first time y'all please welcome john
reef everybody welcome to the honeydew
job thank you be seated good just good
to be here thanks for having me man
you're welcome i really appreciate it
it's been a minute it's we've been going
back and forth for a while yeah well i
feel like we're ships passing in the
night anyway you know uh you're always
on the road i'm always on the road and
you're based here i'm in north carolina
but it's it's good we're doing it so
before we get into what we're gonna talk
about please plug promote everything
john reap okay well i also do a podcast
with all things comedy right here
countryishcountryish.com
uh it's audio it's video we're on
youtube or on facebook we go live every
tuesday night i give money away
yeah tell them about that yeah so i mean
i get residual checks i've done some
random acting gigs over the years some
movies sitcoms i get them in the mail
all the time and they're usually 11.47
you know what i mean it's not a big deal
uh but people who in the real world they
don't know this stuff they think you
know
actors who get residual checks are
loaded or something so as a way of
proving that this is kind of a [ __ ]
thing
i get them all i put them on the table i
grab one uh i don't know what it is i
don't know what it's for i open it and i
tell you what it is and and how it's
airing and people call in with guesses
closest person i will literally sign it
over i get i put their name on it i say
to the paid to the order of
and i [ __ ] put it in the mail i love
it and so i've been burned a couple of
times though how what how do you get it
open
um i did a show with tignatory because
wait i'm sorry i don't mean interrupt
but you say you're doing this blind is
that what you mean okay yeah so you
haven't you have no idea yourself yeah
okay you already opened it i'm trusting
it's two dollars right five dollars i've
legit got one from comedy central before
and i took a picture of it i think it
was for
honest to god it cost more to mail it to
me yeah yeah and what was it
right so i mean
not all of them i mean you get the one
right after if it's a big movie you do
it depends on how you get paid and all
this crap but mostly they're jokes in
fact there's a bar in studio city called
residuals yeah i know exactly i've been
there and i took my resi first residual
check there yeah yeah so
if you don't know you get a you get a
drink yeah um for for whatever that
really you could take oh residual
check-ins if you've got a two-cent check
you're getting a drink for two cents and
they used to and they used to put them
on the wall and like you know the
bragging rights was the cheapest one you
know but yeah so i opened them on the
show
and i got burned because i did a show
with tignotaro called one mississippi it
was on amazon prime
and it was great but you know it wasn't
like a big hit or anything and i got
paid okay on it and then i just forgot
about it i just went away i just hadn't
you know and i guess they just bought it
in germany or some foreign market like
it was a big buyout yeah and i was like
it was like 900 some dollars so i had to
give you know i don't know if they can
even cash them like i don't even do that
part i'm like you got one week to
contact me
and i and other than that it's over i
love it and so you lost 900 on that and
then i lost
another one i lost a thousand dollars
yeah my own producer was telling me like
dude you want to cheat this and just
open them yeah you could i'm like i
could but that kind of ruins the
spontaneity and i want people to know
there's a chance you're going to get a
check for 900 thousand dollars 900 000
no no 900 overthoughts okay yeah i
yeah yeah so we uh country ish we give
monty away i do a bit called small town
news where we we uh look for the weird
crazy stories happen in small towns i'll
give you the headline of my favorite
story from last year and it's just a
headline a louisiana woman bites a camel
in the balls
in order to save her deaf dog's life
at a truck stop in florida
[Music]
[Laughter]
so they're in florida there was a truck
stop of course that had like a little
petting zoo and this lady stopped to get
gas and i mean she was all messed up on
pills too
and her dog got away from her and it
went behind the gate and the dog was
deaf so she couldn't call it like come
back over here this camel sat on the dog
and then this lady had to
jump over the fence to save the dog
dogging that sat on her i don't know i
don't know camels sit on people
and then just to get out of there she
had to bite it in the balls and then you
meet the lady like there's a video of it
and it worked that's right it's one of
my favorite small town news stories we
did last year that's [ __ ] great so we
have a good time i got i do with my
buddies in in north carolina
and uh and we have like you know
comedians will zoom in we have a who's
zoom and who kind of thing and uh
comedians will zoom in we've had a lot
of them i want to get you on as well
asap i will do it yeah so country ish
i'm doing i'm still touring all the time
in fact i think this weekend i'll be in
dc at the comedy loft
um
you can go if you go to countryish.com
tour dates merch all that crap's right
there all right that's what i've been
working on mostly yeah for you yeah
um so let's talk a little bit about it
so are you from north carolina born and
raised hickory north carolina okay yeah
it used to be the furniture capital of
the world
isn't jordan is jordan from hickory no
jordan is from north carolina but he's
from a town outside of hickory and i
can't remember i want to say he's closer
to wilmington he's more coastal but yeah
that's a that's a great one uh michael
jordan
uh i live in like nascar country kind of
yeah it used to be the like i said
furniture capital home to winston cup
champion dale jarrett
and i want to say maybe the pig from
green acres
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
so you recently
uh you were living here you said for
what 18 19 i was in uh yeah so i was out
here 18 years um i was in studio city
uh did well you know did one last comic
stand
and toured around and i was on rodney
carrington had a sitcom i've
done some movies so my career is always
kind of like this and then i moved back
to north carolina yeah why did you move
back well it was a combination of things
i started
really missing my family because a lot
had happened without me like i would go
home and visit for christmas
and then be hanging out with some
friends and family and they would start
talking about a story
and i had no idea i wasn't involved and
i i just felt like i was missing out i
had fomo and so i'm thinking too like
well my career it's always kind of done
this and the technology is changing the
industry's changing you could be
anywhere and audition when i got on um
east bound and down on hbo yeah that was
just me recording it uh at home i
happened to be visiting my parents that
weekend and i got the audition and i
made my mom read with me she was reading
[ __ ] danny mcbride's life
i love it
and my mom who's like the sweetest
southern baptist lady she never cusses
she stepped right up she goes i'll help
you and i'm just read these these lines
and then you know you're not gonna be on
camera i just need to hear you and i'll
do my part
and it's like you know i told that
goddamn [ __ ] and i'm like
mom
so that was weird
but uh
but yeah so that's my thought was like
why do i need to be here unless it's
just a comedy store you know to hang out
and do spots and even then i was getting
kind of lazy about that because as the
older i get the more lazy i got i go on
the road for like three four days i come
back i got two or three days off and i'm
just like just gonna chill you know i
got a buddy named kyle we would hang out
and some other friends but other than
that
that was really it and
i thought well what i'll do is i'll fix
my town home up i'll put it on the
market and see what happens
and it was like
was it it was quick an offer above what
i was
and i'm like okay this is a sign so
i sold it
i flew my dad out first class
and uh we went and got a big camper and
a
hooked it up to my car and we drove all
my [ __ ] back
from l.a to north carolina by the way
i'm just i'm sitting here shaking my
head so i'm just so jealous of that oh
yeah yeah my father died when i was 16.
so you're telling me like so you have a
really great relationship with your dad
yeah i had a great day i still i mean
he's had a stroke but that's what we're
going to talk about yeah but he so you
flew him out first class i flew him out
first class and you got what did you get
to drive across well i had a uh what was
it the fifth wheel you have a fifth
wheel no we had a i had an suv it was a
mercury mountaineer okay that's what i
had
and then my dad went out we were gonna
get a u-haul but you couldn't there were
no u-hauls available because everyone
was this is on the cusp of everyone
getting out of town but i mean it's
before cove it was before but people
were kind of just
leaving so
um it was impossible to rent a u-haul
there was none available like we tried
and then he goes well we'll just buy one
you know i'll look online we'll buy a it
was like one of them uh
baked potato looking things yeah i mean
it was just that and we hooked it up to
the
to the mountaineer and we just we made a
bed in the back of the mountaineer and
put all our stuff in the trailer so we
took turns driving yeah so
first shift he's driving and we'll hang
out and then if he got tired he'd get
back and sleep great we didn't get a
hotel room
we i mean that's supposed to be a three
or four day trip yeah we did it in like
i don't know 70 something hours we just
stopped to get gas
use the bathroom get some food and we're
back on the road again so that was kind
of precious pictures of it yeah yeah i
can send you some pictures so the bed
looks pretty cool kind of photoshopped
[Laughter]
it was a you're right when you say that
like you know like i missed out on that
i was taking it for granted there was
one
a lot of people whose fathers and
parents are alive don't do that no you
know what i mean like what a great thing
to do yeah yeah well he's been wanting
me to come home for a while tell me
about your dad let's talk about your dad
growing up like what sort of dad was he
what kind of relationship he's funny
dude he was the class clown in his group
he's the funny one that's where i get it
i get it from him
so my dad
uh
i would watch
my
my dad make his friends laugh
you know and they already do power in
because it was above my head i just
remember like no i'm sorry what do you
do for a living oh i thought you meant
the bits
i don't remember what he said uh he was
a he worked at a goodyear for a while
he's a manager of a good year and he was
a deputy sheriff before that okay and he
got shot he almost died
what happened when i was six or seven
this happened so he was a deputy sheriff
he was
uh off duty but he still had the scanner
in his car
and he heard a call come in about a guy
beating his wife or something
and he just when he heard the address he
knew oh i'm i'm right here i'm just
gonna stop in and see if she's okay so
he went to the door
and
you know the guy
they they started fighting like he came
at my dad and they're fighting and now
this guy's running and they're chasing
each other
and
he had
circled around and gotten behind some
what the other guy
behind a wood pile or something and my
dad kind of like flanked him and
long story short my dad had his gun and
he he came up behind him and put it to
his head said it's over raise your hands
i got you
he didn't know he had a 22. so this dude
pulls this 22 out and raises his hands
like this and just goes
the point blank right here and one hit
him in the stomach
one hit him in the hand
and then he backed up and unloaded on
that guy killed that guy holy [ __ ]
yeah and now he's got a he still has a
bullet in his spine because it's too
close we're talking hickory 1976
okay
they ain't [ __ ] with that they're
like can you move your wiggle your toe
you're good sew him up don't worry about
that numbness that's gonna be permanent
so he was lucky to survive that
and he got in when they they so they've
he had a colostomy bag for a while
they when they sewed him back up
they didn't do something right and he
had septic shock and they had to go back
in and get all the septic you know out
of his blood yeah he was like hurting
himself uh so
yeah so that was when i was a kid
uh he was a deputy sheriff how many uh
siblings i got one younger brother okay
yeah and were your parents together at
this time okay are you still together
yeah okay yeah
they're still together i remember waking
up as a kid it was a saturday morning it
was april fool's day when it happened
and my dad's the funny guy and of course
he would do that to my mom
send another trooper with the wife
saying you need to come with us david's
been shot on april fools she was like i
don't believe it it's april fools i know
what's up and then the wife comes out
and she's like oh [ __ ] this is real and
so i just remember waking up saturday
morning and there was a babysitter there
i'm like who are you i'm like where's my
mom
oh she's at the hospital i was like what
happened to my mom she does nothing
she's fine i'm like okay i've just let
it go for a minute wait
where's my dad
uh oh he got shot so i remember that
conversation babysitter's telling you
yeah your dad got it yeah cause they're
in the hospital trying to figure this
out i couldn't imagine having to tell a
seven-year-old that's my daughter's age
right now like hey your dad got shot i
couldn't imagine having to tell a little
kid you know it's funny as of my kid
can you imagine
it was just well you're so young you
don't understand
what's happening is your brother younger
than you yeah he's a year and a half
younger i'm saying i was seven or eight
i really it's 77 so maybe no maybe it
was
maybe i was younger than that maybe i
was like five or six but
yeah
i couldn't ima i want to find out who
the babysitter is i should ask my mom
who was that lady yeah because that
would be an interesting conversation to
have with her like how did you
deliver that news to two kids hey listen
you're going to babysit my kids tonight
okay what should we do tonight read
books
we'll see you later put on tom and jerry
and see how long it lasts before they
turn around go who are you yeah give
them some pop tarts
but yeah it was a crazy thing
um and is that what made him get out of
the force yeah so after that
mom said no more of this
and he goes i i agree
and uh he had a job before that where he
was working at a tire place you know as
a salesman selling tires and that kind
of [ __ ]
so he went back to that and became a
manager
of a goodyear tire and auto part and
that was what he did most of his life
but he has a scar like this is the funny
side of him like we would go to a beach
and he would take his shirt off
and you would see the scars
like the bullet wound wouldn't you be
too i would too i don't know if i'd wear
a shirt ever again yeah i don't care
what my body looks like like you mean
these bulldogs
well what was weird about it was it was
in the shape of what a perfect six-pack
would kind of look like no because it
was like one cut here a cut here then
another one here because he had to go
back in so he had a
built-in sort of a six-pack on top of
his gut like this he looks just like me
and so he would take his shirt off and
be like what are we talking about i'm
ripped
it's like i earned this six-pack he was
proud of it yeah
there's a bullet sitting in my spot
right he has a bullet and he still has
it in there yeah still has it in there
and uh
and that gun that he used to kill the
other guy so later on in life you know
as i got older through the years i would
always revisit and ask questions and i
want to ask you like have you ever asked
him what it's like to take another man's
life yeah he goes on how much he feared
losing his yeah
he he told me when he got shot
like all of a sudden training popped in
his head of like be calm
don't freak out because you're gonna
pump the blood quicker and you're gonna
lose you're gonna bleed out good point
so he said he remembers like it was some
like boy scout training that he had
would you if you get bit by snake he's
supposed to be
worst pain ever he's like swallowing a
hot rock he said it was horrible and
then of course like people don't think
about the heat that [ __ ] that's coming
out of that gun at that speed like just
burning the [ __ ] out of you too yeah
yeah and 22s that's the ones that they
used to you know for assassinations
because the idea of a 22 is to bounce
around
and so that kind of happened and it just
landed
it's lucky where it landed i mean
because it had moved and you hear the
story all the time but you were two
seconds or two centimeters over from
death or perilously but yeah so he he
got lucky where it landed but so let's
talk about this for a second so hit guys
arms are up bang bang bang bang bang
bang and then your dad what falls back
yeah but is he still standing would you
take that he still stacks his back yeah
that's what he told me he hit him and he
had no vest he already had his gun in
his hand oh yeah because he's off duty
yeah no vest right he was wearing uh
regular clothes yeah um which maybe is
the reason why this guy didn't know he
was a cop or something i don't know
there's a lot of gray area there but i
remember
he said when he got shot
he already had his gun and it was an
instinct just to shoot back and he got
him in the neck
and then these other guys that at that
point had come and surrounded him they
all shot him like later in life i wasn't
so they both didn't lay there alive like
one's dying and the other one might be
dying they killed that dude yeah asap
right then and there you can shoot a cop
it's
and so i remember like she had polaroids
of this dude like this is what he looked
like after
we shot him shot him yeah he showed them
to you yeah he still wore you
oh probably 10.
he like hey
when i tell you not to do something
check out these pictures
i'm like
yeah every morning and every night i
journal i don't know if you guys do that
but i do i do a positivity journal every
morning every night and i promise you it
has saved my life it's changed the way i
think
and it's an integral part of my day all
right and the new year is here and there
is no better way to kick off 2022 than
by making sure you're feeling your best
self one stick of liquid iv and 16
ounces of water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone and it
comes in incredible hydration flavors
like watermelon lemon lime strawberry
pina colada and more i take my favorite
is the uh the orange one uh it's got
vitamin c
um it's got everything i like the flavor
all of it i can actually taste that one
and i'm gonna tell you right now my
daughter just went through another we
all just went through another round of
covid and i'm taking them every day and
have been since they've been giving them
to me i take one a day every single day
i don't have my dehydration headaches
anymore i don't have any of that stuff
all right they are healthier than sugary
sports drinks there's no artificial
flavors or preservatives and there's
less sugar than an apple it's made with
clean ingredients it's non-gmo it's
vegan and free of gluten dairy and soy
liquid iv is on a mission to change the
world and has donated over 19 million
servings globally grab your liquid iv in
bulk nationwide at costco or you can get
25 off when you go to liquidive.com and
use code honeydew at checkout that's 25
off of anything you order when you get
better hydration today using promo code
honeydew at
liquidiv.com a lot of people didn't even
make resolutions this year and you know
what i get it but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't still find a way to shake
things up whether it's by switching up
your workout routine or going someplace
new whatever way you challenge yourself
this new year there's no better way to
do it than with a pair of raycom
wireless earbuds in your ears raycon
wireless earbuds are the best way to
bring audio with you because no matter
how much you shake things up literally
no matter how much you shake you know
they won't fall out of your ears their
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever there's also awareness
mode for when you need to listen to your
surroundings so you can take raycons
with you wherever you go with optimized
gel tips for the perfect and ear fit
these earbuds are so comfortable and
they will not budge trust me i wear them
all the time i wear them working out i
take them on tour with me traveling they
never fall out i can adjust them so i
can hear people talking to me it doesn't
shut out the surroundings i'm not
hearing my or miss my daughter yelling
for me if i'm wearing them in the house
rakons offers eight hours of play time
and a 32 hour battery life and they're
priced just right you get quality audio
at half the price of other premium audio
brands it's no wonder raycon's everyday
earbuds have over 48 thousand five star
reviews right now honeydew listeners can
get 15 off their raycon order at
byraycon.com
honeydew that's by raycon.com
honeydew to save fifteen percent on ray
cons by raycon.com
honeydew now let's get back to the duke
so he took polaroids and he kept him on
yeah he had him in a shoe box and
every couple of years i'd i'd ask him
questions and he'd pull out different
things and
so that gun that he used like he gave it
to me i now have that that gun it was a
revolver it's about the gun that took
them a man's life yeah and one in
self-defense in self-defense but also he
also shot the bed one time with that
same one
yeah so it's got one and a half kills
all
right
that was a he was trying to show me gun
safety
and was like no and it went off he
i don't he my dad's crazy
he's like all right
what i do my routine is i uh
i make sure the safety's on
okay so i put it on and then i'll point
it at the bed and i'll just pull the
trigger to make sure it works and as he
did that he already had it on and when
he was trying to demonstrate to me he
had turned it off yeah yeah and then he
pulled and just hit the bed i mean shot
and then you couldn't hear [ __ ]
if i shot a gun in here right now we
wouldn't be able to hear each other for
like 10 seconds maybe longer so
yeah yeah yeah yeah so but yeah so he
killed the bed and killed a guy with it
what have you ever told him about what
it was really like to because i mean
immediately he's going to
the guys are coming not like i just
killed the guys if ever [ __ ] well he was
just trying to stay alive he would at
that moment he didn't yeah he was just
that guy tried to kill me so he hated
that guy oh god this
so later in life
um
i forgot why but i think maybe him and
my mom had just come back from a class
reunion
so they were a little bit tipsy or
something and mom was driving and i
don't know i don't even remember why i
was in the car but i remember him
telling my mom go up here take a left
and she's like david i'm not doing that
and he's like go take a left now
and i didn't know what was happening
apparently this has happened before me
yeah i could say by the way you said
your mom oh my god
i'm like what's happening
and
and so they went to that dude's grave oh
his grave i thought you were gonna say
he took it to the spot where it went
down no he went to the dude's grave and
my dad peed on it
he hates this guy
so when i tell him
took a piss [ __ ] yeah and i'm like so
when i try to say like what does it feel
like do you ever feel remorseful
i don't think that that it's in there i
think it's like i'm going to this
now there's probably more that i don't
know
that he probably has tried to process
over the years i'm sure he went to
therapy
but i remember that i gotta say that's
probably really good therapy to me
dude 100 there's no relief a therapist
can give you like that right there
that [ __ ] happened
i saw you go i forgot about this yeah
yeah it just hit me like i was trying to
think of like what what how did he get
through this and then as soon as i said
like oh yeah he [ __ ] peed on that
dude's grave man um but yeah
that was but he really kind of
as i grew up he just shifted away from
that life like he went really deep into
being a great dad
a great husband i mean i'm sure that
gave him a new perspective yeah in life
oh yeah in short
i think and i don't know
a hundred percent because my parents
don't tell me everything about them
they keep some of it to for them
i'm learning things as i go because i
just moved in with my mom like three
years ago my mom's my roommate now i was
gone for 18 years yeah that's why i sit
down next to a recliner and watch tv
with
so i'm learning new stuff you know but
um
so
for ever since that shooting
my dad when he would get a valentine's
day card or a christmas card he didn't
sign it david or your husband he signed
it newman
and i didn't know like what was it what
does he like alfred e newman i mean he
kind of did he was like but i realized
he's he's saying new man
i'm a new man like they went through
something
and then that him getting shot changed
him he autographs i think yeah newman so
i'm like oh that's pretty cool but i
don't i don't know what it was they went
through before that you know there's
probably some shaky shaky times in the
marriage oh i mean how long they've been
together oh my god i mean
50 over 50 years how could there not be
shaky times life life's thrown whatever
it wants at you yeah
yeah has he ever taken you to the spot
where it went down
he may have i don't remember a lot about
that i'm taking [ __ ] he's like i'm gonna
think yeah right here
you gotta go all right can you hold it
for 10 minutes
let's go very everybody get out get out
of here oh yeah
right
oh man man but he's like he was a funny
one like i didn't that was that happened
so young in my life that i i didn't see
him as a certain like a real badass cop
i just saw him as a goofy dad sure
because he made a 180 turn he said i'm
gonna be that now well also
statistically they say that most police
officers never even fire their right
their gun and here he is with a
like a moment his life or death you know
yeah and and only being in the force not
that many years so yeah i get it [ __ ]
that yeah so so he's he was done but i
mean he would check in every now and
then just recertified so he could have
his gun legally and all this stuff but
but he was a funny dude and so as a kid
i remember like you know that have
parties over at the house and my dad's
friends would be all around and i could
tell
when something happened everyone would
look at my dad like what's david gonna
say because he was the f they looked up
to him and i was like oh that's kind of
that's power there's power in that
and so to me
well i all i tried to do was make my dad
laugh if i i felt like if i can make my
dad laugh then i'm i'm a funny dude
because everyone thinks he's the funny
one so that's kind of where it came from
he just he was a practical joker
um but yeah that's that's kind of where
it started the the comedy love for
comedy for me
um because i grew up watching cartoons
um my dad got me into like saturday
night live yeah like he was a big chevy
chase steve martin fan
i remember like not many people made my
dad laugh and when
watching him laugh at uh
well sounds weird now bill cosby
um bill cosby himself that one special
is probably one of the funniest things
ever because it was clean and it was
just great stories
and the whole family could watch it
together that's about to say it's all
family-friendly yeah yeah and uh i
remember like just him just he-hauling
at this and me thinking like that's what
i want to do one day i don't know how
i'm going to do this or what's going to
happen but
it would be nice if that if i could make
my dad laugh like bill cosby did you
know that i'm a funny guy
yeah
and that's what set it off for you yeah
yeah just trying to make him laugh
because he was the funny one and my
brother was um
not funny my mom he's funny in a
different way
like if i were at a party
and
i was i jumped on a table and was
drinking vodka and put my pulled my
pants down and did something stupid he
would walk over with a lampshade and go
put this on your head
[Laughter]
he just throws fuel on the fire and
walks away
yeah
yeah
so
excuse me you mentioned your dad had a
stroke and
did you move back because he had a
stroke or when you moved back it
happened later
yeah so you move back because i kind of
stroke and the pandemic correct wow
stroke first pandemic second so it was
thanksgiving day
and
we were uh we had the family over and we
were waiting for one more uh couple to
come over or whatever and we hadn't
eaten it but the the room smelled of
like turkey we got a bojangles turkey
that year i remember this the first time
we got a bojangles turkey which is
delicious
you know deep fried turkey no bojangles
ever no
since i've been in the south south yeah
they got a good spicy rub which is great
but
we uh
i remember him he was sitting on the
hearth
next to the fireplace and he was just
kind of listening to everybody else tell
their stories and he was just kind of
having a moment and i just remember him
just
he just fell over he just hit his head
really hard on the floor and i
i was my first thought always is he's
joking
i started laughing i was like hi good
one he i thought maybe he was making a
joke about like i got low blood sugar i
hadn't eaten yet we were going to eat
and so he just hit the floor and i kind
of laughed and then jason's like no
that's he he hit really hard like he was
a big old gash on his head
he's like he hit too hard for that to be
a joke he doesn't have that commitment
to laugh that much
and i'm like oh [ __ ] then you see the
hand come up and and then and then it's
on
and
we don't know what's happening
thanksgiving you're dialing 9-1-1 i i
called 9-1-1 i had i had just had
shoulder surgery so i couldn't do
anything physically to help all i could
do my brother and my buddy mark were
over there trying to straighten him out
trying to figure out what's happening
and i'm just i go straight to nine and
one mom's crying at the house yeah it's
probably
six seven we're waiting for other people
to get there
and they came pretty quick
um
i got to ask you a question
did the paramedics beat that couple
but what do you mean did the paramedics
get to your house for that final couple
did
they had to come to the hospital
they went to the house i was like
what's going on here look at that
put another hospital
they're late
we went to the hospital yeah
[Laughter]
i'm trying to think of who it actually
was that was late because it's so much
of a blur
but uh yeah we went to the hospital what
well what happened to him was he had uh
kidney stones
a week or two before this
and they did a lipton i forgot what it's
called it's something where they do uh
they blast them yeah the radar or
whatever sound waves or something i
don't know
and so
and he had you know he just he had
cholesterol
and
i think one of those something a blood
clot was lodged because there's a lot of
internal bleeding and it caused the
stroke and they you know
i think we even have a lawsuit in our
hands because
at the hospital we took him to
they you know they couldn't do a certain
procedure because they thought he would
bleed out
something to thin the blood but couldn't
do that because he just had this
procedure where the second hospital we
went to later did they leave that
hospital yeah how long it was
thanksgiving day there was no one it was
no doctor they were you know
so they were like scrambling
and
they they the other hospital which is a
better hospital which is an hour and a
half from our house
said oh no the brain always trumps
anything else so if there's something
wrong with the brain you risk it and you
fix the brain and and knowing that now
we would have done something different
but
he's paralyzed on his left side he's in
a skilled nursing facility
how old is he now 77 and he's is that
permanent the paralyzation yeah
yeah i mean they always give you a
center yeah well we took him to
different rehab places
we took him to
i mean
different hospitals because he got
covered one time and had to be rushed
from the skilled nursing facility to a
hospital
he survived that i mean this guy's been
shot
he's got a stroke he had coveted during
the stroke he's got titanium knees can't
kill the smile
he won't die but is he there mentally
still and everything sometimes sometimes
yeah well he's also medicated
and i know he enjoys because when he got
shot the first time
there was a moment where like we got to
get him off [ __ ] meth or whatever it
was not math not math
not meth what is it called nov
oxies and the painkillers and all that
purposes that's a different one back
then but they had to get him off that
that was the whole thing so now he's
back
he knows what that feels good
and they'll give it to you if you feel
bad
so i think when i go in there to visit
him it's
hit or miss it's like is he going to be
all there or is he just he'll see [ __ ]
you know he'll hallucinate it gets uti
you're going to attract infections all
the time
um what's that like for you to see him
like that
horrible
because he's he's a strong dude
and then he's what he's he lost all of
his teeth there in coburn
during coven they were short staffed
um we couldn't go visit my mom wasn't
allowed to go there
uh it's up to her she's going every day
she's made that her new thing in life is
like i'm just gonna go visit him and
make sure he's they're doing what they
say they're supposed to do or whatever
she'll go
but then covet they couldn't get in
there and so and then they're short
staffed and then they'd ignore his teeth
they'll come in there and do the bare
minimum give him food and do a thing
give him a medicine and pop out
uh so all of his teeth
all of them rotted and they had to be
pulled so now he has no teeth
he is paralyzed on one side he's
with with her down to nothing he's like
100 some pounds he's supposed to be 220.
and uh
yeah it is it sucks seeing him like that
but i think
because he wants everything to be cool
with us he doesn't make it sound as bad
as it is
he'll do some light joking here and
there
we'll watch tv together there's a nice
little recliner in there i'll go in
there and just camp out with him
sometimes and we'll watch tv together
um but i think we're both trying to help
each other through this i don't know
what the end is going to be i don't
think he's going to get out of there
because he's not motivated he doesn't
want to get up and exercise he's kind of
a lazy guy
you know just naturally like like me i
love the recliner i go home and get in
the recliner that's what he does
and so
i think there's part of him it's like
well i'm 77. it's not like i'm gonna run
a triathlon i'm gonna i'm gonna it's
gonna be here you know so
it sucks
now you're a dad right yes yeah i have a
son tucker he's 23. tell me about that
you were
what you're 20 yeah in my 20s uh i was
with a girl and married nope nope this
was this was uh sort of a whoopsie-daisy
as they say
and i love him tucker's the best he's
more manly than me i think the manliness
skipped a generation it went from my dad
to my to my son
yeah
like i got the
sort of funnyness from him but not like
the blue collar stuff as much
because tucker is uh he made straight
a's in high school he wrestled he played
football
he hunts he fishes he goes uh like he's
a welder like he's a traveling welder
get his own camper and will drive to
certain jobs and just stay there until
something's finished
he's doing good he makes a lot of money
is he in north carolina he's in north
carolina he just got engaged to his
girlfriend yeah
so he's doing well but in the beginning
it was it was kind of rocky because i
was in
i was living in raleigh so i left
hickory
in 1992
yeah 92 to go to school at nc state
which is in raleigh that's about three
hours
so when i went to school in raleigh i
would just come home to visit here and
here and there you know what i mean
um
and i met a girl in hickory we hooked it
up
she got pregnant and it's like what are
we gonna do i didn't know what to do she
did she wasn't sure what we're gonna do
but
we went through it and it was a little
rocky
because we
didn't see eye to eye on everything sure
but over time it's like well this is
what it is and uh i just i just tried to
be the best i could from where i was
because then i had moved to los angeles
and so i would just fly back just to see
him and the family from time to time so
i wasn't an everyday dad and that sucks
you know because that's not the kind of
dad i wanted to be i wanted to be like
my dad yeah and now i'm
which kind of made me mad i felt like i
was forced in this position because i
already the comedy career was on the
rise uh there was you know uh
festivals i was invited like montreal
was like you you know i was a new face i
felt like i can't just
not do this you know so i was like what
you're making me you're making me a bad
dad and i hated it
so you hated comedy for that
yeah well i hated comedy for that i kind
of was mad at the mother for that oh
nice in a weird way
so but i got over that and um
and now it's great everything's good now
yeah that's another reason why i want to
friendly with her yeah yeah we're fine
that's another reason why i wanted to go
home though was to sort of like fix that
make sure this is good
dad mom my brother
all my friends so it was a combination
of all those things of uh why i went
home then the stroke then the pandemic
but yeah yeah
he's great i i flew him out here right
before i left tucker first class
did i find first only bag
i don't remember i have to ask him that
that's a good question i don't think i
did
i think that's reserved for old i'll
call my dad
listen if you're in your twenties man
get the [ __ ] back yeah put everybody in
yeah you know yeah he wasn't 21 yet so
he couldn't even drink anyway in first
class so yeah it's wasted yeah it's just
a little extra [ __ ] room exactly a
lot of poor man's first class back there
now though with that middle seat
available yes i don't mind flying back
there these days if that middle seat's
available i'm like all right man we got
a little [ __ ] room back that's all i
need
it's all i need yeah
oh i i flow i've flown so much that i
just i got all these points and
you know i get bumped into first for
free a lot of times if it's like try to
fly on a day where it's if i can like a
thursday or
or a tuesday
you know because there's less people out
there but
um i brought him out to la and
showed him my my condo before we left
and we had a good moment and i took him
all the spot took him to the comedy
store he did yeah that's cool yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he saw me perform
before that but
yeah and he's funny kid too um you got
to see your name on the wall yeah yeah
take him back to the little green room
area that was just for comics and
he got to experience all that before i
left but um
yeah uh
that's that's
one of the big reasons i moved back home
not just dad not just mom or brother but
tucker
yeah to be a dad yeah more of a dad to
be more of a dad be in his life let him
know look i'm you know my career is at a
moment where i don't have to be in la
anymore you know we were saying before
this
i mean covert made it even easier in a
weird way but before that even i got
eastbound and down on
a tape and so i'm like what am i doing
look what i've already missed
i'm not gonna miss anymore
and so good for you that help
yeah today's program is brought to you
by athletic greens the health and
wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
really simple with so many stressors in
life it's difficult to maintain
effective nutritional habits and give
our bodies the nutrients it needs to
thrive busy schedules poor sleep
exercise the environment work stress or
simply not eating enough of the right
foods can leave us deficient in key
nutritional areas one tasty scoop of
ag-1 contains 75 vitamins minerals and
whole-food-sourced ingredients including
a multi-vitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more in one
convenient daily serving the special
blend of high quality bioavailable
ingredients and a scoop of ag-1 work
together to fill the nutritional gaps in
your diet support energy and focus aid
with gut health and digestion and
support a healthy immune system
effectively replacing multiple products
or pills with one healthy delicious
drink join the movement of athletes moms
dads rookies first timers and everyone
in between taking ownership of their
daily health and focusing on the
nutritional products they really need in
the simplest manner possible to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you an immune supporting free one year
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs with your first purchase if you
visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew today again
simply visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take control of your health
and give ag-1 a try cheers to 2022 and
resolutions you can actually keep how
about having clean and shiny balls all
year round well our sponsors at manscape
are here to save your balls this year
and make the ball drop into 2022 the
cleanest and sexiest ever set your first
new year's resolution with good
intentions and join the four million men
worldwide who trust manscape with our
exclusive offer go to manscape.com and
use the code honeydew for 20 off plus
free shipping inside the performance
package 4.0 you'll find the signature
lawnmower 4.0 this electric trimmer is
designed to trim hair on loose skin the
advanced skin safe technology reduces
cuts and nicks on your delicate nuts it
also comes equipped with a 4000 k led
spotlight that will shine a light to the
promised land 2022 looks to be a
grooming routine is not complete without
applying crop preserver and crop reviver
before showing off your 2022 self these
unique formulations take care of the
smelliest part of your body and are a
big boost to your confidence into the
new year to complete the set manscape
threw in their shed travel bag and
anti-chafing boxer briefs as free gifts
to keep all your goodies stored
comfortably whether your resolution is
to work out more or travel to new places
be sure to travel to manscape.com for
our exclusive offer of 20 off plus free
shipping with the code honeydew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
honeydew at manscape.com that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use code honeydew it's new year no pubes
in 2022 with manscape now let's get back
to the do i mean talk to me about
just also the the hindsight that you
have with time you know your dad the
time you guys have had i mean he's 23
already yeah right you know how fast
that [ __ ] goes yeah
so what are you doing right now to to
maximize time with them do you get to
see him a lot yeah you do yeah well
definitely holidays
um how close do you live
well he lives in charlotte now but
that's only about 45 minutes okay yeah
it's as much as we can do because his
job now makes him travel a lot
so he's based
he lives with his girlfriend fiance in
charlotte she's going to school for like
her master's degree
and so he bases himself there but then
also drives his camper to where he needs
to wherever he's going to work and that
could be pennsylvania florida sure but
we i took him on a cruise i've been
doing a cruise
so every year
that kovac kind of threw this messed us
up
um i make sure that my mom
i'm engaged now
my fiancee and my brother
and uh my son and his girl can all go on
this cruise together and so we do
we do that at least and of course the
holidays and just as much as it can just
hanging out so
it's it's it's really just up to him
at this point you know how much we can
do it but
i want to go hunting fishing with him
you do i want him to teach me that
lifestyle because i didn't even though
my dad had guns and all this stuff i
only went fishing maybe one time
i've never been hunting i just picture
your dad shooting a deer and then
walking over and pissing on it
like that's how you listen how i feel
one shot
walks over pisses on it
and like we'll come back later don't
worry we'll come back that's great yeah
um
what is it that you hope to to at least
get
out of the relationship you have with
your dad the time remaining because you
just said you don't know if he's gonna
get out of it yeah i doubt it so what do
you hope to get out of that honest
moments
i like visiting when it's just me
because he's a different
if it's just me like we have a thing
cause i'm i'm like my dad and my
brother's kind of like my mom
and so
we get each other my dad and i get each
other even though he gets on my nerves
and i get on his nerves we have the same
wavelength
so i like to go visit him by myself not
when my mom's in the room because when
she's in there it's like there's a nurse
and she's making him he's like i wanna
you know but i'm there it's just
straight up you know honest
conversations so i like to try and get
real conversations out of him and
or or random stuff i
i just asked him other days like dad you
still get boners you know just out of
nowhere he's like
i woke up with one i woke up with a wall
i got my good hand here so it's hard to
watch
porn and then put the thing down and
grab it like this
so we had we just talked about him
trying to jerk off
you know
so
you still gotta lose yeah
yeah
and so
oh i gotta tell you this one
i feel kind of bad about it but not
really it's great
so and i don't know if he was [ __ ]
with me
or if this was a real thing that went
through his brain okay so my dad had a
catheter in his penis oh i it just makes
me yeah every time i'm like
kill me yeah for real i don't want i
don't want whatever that is
take me out take me out i don't want
anything going in that hole dude my legs
squeezing over here now man just
thinking about it
so he had to do that a couple times
anyway
i'm sitting there next to him and this
lady comes in and she's taking this
diaper off and she's got the catheter
she's going to change the catheter and
i'm just like sitting there like i don't
want to see this i'm just going to turn
my head i pretend to do something on my
phone
and then i look over and i see this
nurse
now his dick is out and it's just
splayed out there
and it's a good-looking nurse she had
bright red lipstick
and he
i just looked at him looking at her lips
he's staring at her lips
as his penis is out and she's doing
stuff
he just goes
i think you better take the lipstick off
first
and she didn't know what he meant
like dad she's not gonna blow you
but i think he thought like it's trying
to crack me up i think
uh but
what kills me about that statement is
how deep it is it's like
i think you're about to give me a
[ __ ] and i don't want us to get
caught yeah because i'm still married so
please remove the lipstick
idea that my kids right here
whose mom is the same lady i'm worried
about yeah
that's insane
so he still got it yeah i was gonna say
he definitely still got it yeah so i
think would just make his life as
comfortable as possible just go in there
have you thought about sending them a
[ __ ] little
hello masseuse i have have you i've
thought about it but then there's my
mind yeah and then you bring your mom
to her
because she still gets mad at him when
he flirts with nurses
would you 100 yeah yeah that'd be nice
yeah what a what a gift from your bring
some girl
just let him touch the titties
here all right just yeah put your
titties in his face and just bad as
[ __ ] dick around like yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god
i mean is there anything you two have
talked about that really
stands out
uh
in this while he's been paralyzed
well he
sees sometimes he has these
thoughts of like he is getting out of
here i think when he's heavily medicated
he he doesn't
maybe he can't feel that he's not
you know the pain yeah so sometimes
they'll get talking like all right when
i get out of here we're going to do this
we're going to do this what are the
things he wants he wants to get a
certain car like an old
uh buick and he wants to fix it up and
he wants to do
i forgot what because i hear these
things and i just say yeah of course of
course i don't say like well daddy you
can't move i don't piss on his little
dream you can't do that so
and i forgot so i don't always remember
exactly what car it is but it's like a
big hoopty looking old-school 65
buick something
and he wants to fix it up and drive
across the country he wants to stop at
all the different rest stops and there
are historical landmarks and he wants to
do you know he wants to get a camper
like he has these big dreams that he
wants to do talk about that truck stop
in florida
yeah
i know we can get some good camel balls
down
yeah i mean you know uh it's mostly just
what's nice though that you then had
that cross-country trip together
100
and so when you said that i was like
that's true i didn't know i promised
that was gonna be a moment you're going
to remember that the rest of your life
because we didn't think
that we were going to go drive the whole
thing
we're like we just kept pushing each
other like well i can go a little bit
longer
and uh
but even in
true david reap style
i did have a moment where i'm like this
is real special
i'm sitting here with my dad
and
we are driving across the country with
all my stuff i'm leaving kind of you
know it's a big moment
and uh and i was like
turn the radio down just to talk to him
and i was like he goes i don't want to
talk right now
like
i was trying to have a moment he was
just like i'm focused on the road i'm
just trying to stay awake and he's
chewing eyes like you totally shut me
down
like oh okay i thought it was have a
moment um but but looking back at mostly
it was it was
it was good you know um but yeah i i
wish i hadn't done more
stuff like that same i wish i knew i had
this moment this was a couple years ago
so
it's a long story short my father uh had
this boat we used to crab and fish on
and then when he passed one of his good
friends this maryland state trooper
named mr bud
came and bought that boat for me and my
brothers and gave us each a few bucks
and then said as he lived out in the
county and he had a little
barn and everything and he said i'm
gonna keep this boat yeah and if you all
ever want it back you let me know
and i'm telling you fast forward 25
years later my brother's fishing
finds this little piece of trash on the
ground that he picks up just to clean it
up flips it over and it's got this name
bud kellerman on it
and um it's a map for hot spots at the
lake okay so he reaches out to my mother
who gives him mr budd's number
and he calls him he says hey this is uh
derek sickler you know lefty's kid and
uh you know what are you up to he's like
i'm retired now out of the force making
maps for hot spots he's like well that's
how i found you and i was just curious
do you still have my dad's old boat and
he's like some what i tell you and he's
like you said you'd keep it and he's
like i got it for you so he came out
and gave it to my brother and i mean
kept it and my brother's like i gotta
give you something for it and he's like
i'll tell you what give me what i paid
you for it was like a thousand bucks wow
so he gave and he stored it and kept it
so wasn't on the water it was just
somewhere nice kept yeah
my brother gets the boat back and now we
have our dad's boat that we were
children in fishing and crabbing and
stuff in that's amazing so
um he's got the boat at his place and
then he gets a new one uh he buys my
uncle who passed away had a really nice
boat and he bought was a great one
that he used twice before he got sick
okay and it sat garaged and my brother's
like you know what [ __ ] i'm gonna
take that boat my younger brother's now
gonna get my dad's boat oh so i'm with
my
brother
and his two kids and me and my daughter
and we're towing my dad's boat that we
were children in up to my brothers okay
and it's the closest it's i'm the i'm
like you yeah my brother's basically
your dad chewing is like wow whatever he
doesn't
but i'm like man this is the closest
that we'll ever take with uh yeah uh
arrive with our kids and our dad you
know this dead motherfucker's boat being
back here and it just got me it's a
moment it got me yeah it got me and i'm
just telling my brother i'm like you get
it like our kids are in the back seat we
used to be in the kids in the back seat
and that's our dad's boat that we were
on with that like
it gets me and now my brother redid it
and he's got it out on the water with
his kids so it's all [ __ ] great
that's why i'm saying like as soon as
you said that i was like oh what i would
do for us those are a two-day trip with
my dad across the country
and there's moments you don't see them
coming sometimes
it's just
it's a thing it happens you're like
you just wait i talked about it all the
time man you're in the grocery store i'm
opening up the frozen pizza it's just
like oh you hear a song
oh man not right now yeah
there was a there was a moment where um
we were at the the second hospital and
he was out we didn't know if he's going
to wake up because he's kind of like in
a coma for a minute but a stroke just
knocked him out like he was not awake
and uh we're sitting in this in this
room and i'm just
i'm thinking is this it i'm just i'm
starting to prepare eulogies i'm like i
don't know what's going on
and then i hear behind me
and that used to get on my nerves like
he was the loudest snorer on the face of
the planet the one that would wake
himself up you know they did it in
church and got caught but yeah
yeah like it was it was annoying and i
made fun of him i had a whole bit about
it and then when i heard that first it
was the happiest snore i'm like he's
alive isn't it crazy that's the [ __ ] you
hate now make you feel so good yeah
yeah yeah
all right here's what i want to do i
want to switch gears a little bit we've
been we've been i want to hear some
stuff that's a little bit more lighter
okay uh let's hear about this high
school football season
all right so the only sport i was decent
at was football i played
uh you know little league pop one or
whatever you know
and um
like in my seventh or sixth grade year
i got a little bit bigger before these
other kids so i was a middle linebacker
and i was destroying fools like i got
more locker out there huh a little
erlocker out there yes yeah
i had more tackles there was this coach
told me this statistic later i had more
tackles than the rest of the team
combined like i was i was a freaking
headhunter man i just destroyed people
um so to me as a seventh grade john reap
i was going to be in the nfl
you know and so
middle school
not great i think we lost almost every
game in middle school too they get to
high school
new coach comes in
and and i got hurt i mean our team
sucked we were
the redneck school you know we were
mostly a basketball school
like hoosiers indiana kind of thing you
know we had a lot of rednecks and then
some of them could play ball
basketball and the ones who played
basketball did not play football because
the coach was like don't play football
you're going to get hurt so we we didn't
have good athletes i was maybe one of
three on the team that were decent at
all at football but then i stopped
growing i had no business being a middle
linebacker i mean i'm look at me so i
was getting destroyed you know and my
brain i was still a badass but these
guys grew and i was getting run over but
um we lost every game
that we played
and it got to the point
that last game against high brighton
they also 019 no it's a battle of 09.
yeah
the parents that were there are just in
blankets like
just let's just go home
and then that game too i remember making
a lot of tackles and at this point i had
moved back to uh
cornerback
and i had no business doing that either
but
our our defense of line and our our
linebackers were not making the tackle
so i had to run up and do all this stuff
and i was getting k i was getting sore
but anyway
this is like a last play i mean in the
fourth quarter
the score was zero to zero
in the fourth quarter nobody could score
and
at the end of it they kicked a field
goal no not even a touchdown you guys
lost what three we did nothing
[Laughter]
three to nothing
we kept that perfect season the only
thing worse would have been a [ __ ]
safety baby
it's like a soccer score
it was horrible but that was the one
sport i loved and i had a [ __ ] of a
coach kevin wilson this guy who came in
and uh he went on to coach indiana by
the way like this guy actually went on a
little bit of success but then also got
fired because he was such an [ __ ]
kids were quitting our best athletes
were quitting because he was abusive and
and you know
he he didn't know how to coach kids like
high school kids not professional
athletes but it was a it was a horrible
time but there was a but my dad came to
one of my highlights my dad recorded on
vhs camcorder
i was a backup running back yeah i love
how you're doing this
you had to put a vhs in that [ __ ]
out here
you know that's a lot of work to ask
somebody to just stand there what a
whole game like this
but he showed up with his camcorder in a
sunday school class and i remember
i had just recovered a fumble on defense
and the coach goes all right it's the
almost end of the half i'ma let you run
the ball don't fumble i was like you got
a coach
and this little sweet play comes and i
get the ball and that's a counter play
and i'm going this way
the my favorite thing is on the tape if
you watch the tape now because i have
the memory of me being in the scene but
i have a memory of me watching it later
so watching the tape is different uh
me and i was switching hands and the
ball just went up in the air i saw my
feet in the ball
and i i saw my coach's face
but on the tape it goes from like yeah
yeah yeah
and it gets dead quiet
and it just kind of the tape stops
god dang it
all right one more thing i want to talk
to you about because as you mentioned
before you won last comic yes but you
were also on star search
yes previously when arsenio hall was the
host okay uh i remember auditioning for
that i feel like it was at a sheraton at
universal studios i went and did this
thing for star that was years ago that
would have been uh right at 2001
i believe that's probably about 2002
maybe
um
but i got on star search
the host who was oh arsenio was the host
and you know i was
high energy
goofball i was you know
and
i i thought i had a decent set
and then i got i lost the first round
like it's one and done do you remember
who you lost to is that anybody know
yeah um
ben bailey the cash cab oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah and he's great yeah he did
great
and uh i remember carol leifer was one
of the judges and i remember her saying
like no it's i didn't like it it's just
not my cup of tea i i didn't think it
was funny and i just remember like my
career is over
this is it i mean i'm on national tv
people are voting they didn't vote for
me they voted for this guy
i'm out and
my friends are calling me like what
happened i'm like i don't know i thought
i thought i did good
and it was devastating and um
that was 2001 or two and i remember
thinking like this is this is the end of
my career how worse could it get i've
done all this stuff i've done
i've already toured across the country
uh you know i had uh
done montreal just for laughs this is
the moment like all right let's go right
you know
time to perform and it just i ate i
guess i ate [ __ ] i didn't really eat
[ __ ] it was just
it sucked because
there was you have these different
judges
it's a reality show and i mean it's a
contest and i hate that i hate contests
like judging comedy like even when i did
last comic standing i i kind of got
talked into it because i was so
traumatized from the start yeah i was
gonna ask what i'm gonna ask what made
you want to do that
well so my agent's like you know because
they can get you an audition they don't
have to go stand in line he's like all
right well you i can get you an audition
and i turned it down like two or three
years i i just said i don't think i want
to do that because when i would watch at
home i would see
comedians who i know and like
be on stage
uh
you know i have a care in the world kill
their set and then look right in the
camera and go please vote for me
and there's something weird and
desperate about that i didn't like
the way it looked and i remember what
happened to me before so i kind of just
said no
then he calls me up the season i was on
he goes well
they're doing it different you don't
have to live in a house there's not
going to be like a road rules you had to
live and i forgot about that in the
first one or two that's right seasons
they had to live in a house together
it was like tammy pascatelli john
heffron and
um alonzo bowden all these guys lived in
a house together and i'm like i didn't
want to do that and so he goes well you
don't have to live in a house together
and uh they're trying to get like you
know road tested headliners because they
they had some people on the show who
didn't when they get to a club couldn't
do 50 minutes it could only be like the
10 or 15 and that was a problem so they
wanted to get like headliners and then
uh and then they said the prize money is
going up from 50 000 to 250 000.
i'll go down there i didn't think i
would go far
but but i kind of learned from star
search like all right
i'm gonna play it up uh you know they're
gonna look they're gonna make me the
token redneck i already know this so
i'll go down there in the flannel i'll
put my goodyear hat on
and i'll i'll play it up and uh i didn't
think like i said i didn't think i would
get as far as i did but i kind of uh
ended up winning so that was good
that was 2007 season five
all right yeah
um well look man first of all thank you
for coming on here my pleasure i know
what we talked about this was great i
had a great time thank you thanks for
having me on you're welcome thank you i
feel like this is like a good therapy
session i love hearing that a lot of
people say do they okay
yeah uh but now i'm gonna ask you a
question i told you about outside before
we started um advice you would give to
your 16 year old self what would you go
back and say to 16 year old john reed
after everything we've talked about
today from you having a kid yeah
relationship with your dad and now with
your mom in the house and
all that
well
asking me now is a 49 year old guy like
if you'd asked me as a 20-something year
old guy what to do at 16 as a 30 year
old dude what it changes of course and
this in three years you probably have a
different answer than you would say
today yeah so today i would tell 16 year
old self
um
save a little extra cash
you know
be
be diligent about savings
be careful with the credit cards
be careful with the ladies
be very careful of the ladies um
and uh stretch
more [ __ ] yeah i
grew up
looking at stretching there's something
girls doing gymnast i didn't like i hate
it and i'm like i'm stiff as a board now
i would have said drink more water
stretch
save cash
be careful
those are all great brothers
um thank you john for real and one more
time promote whatever you like your
dates all that your podcast yeah but i
do two podcasts one with john heffernan
called heffernan reap and i do
country-ish this i love this one
give it a chance go give me
uh three um
views or listens
and then decide if you're gonna bounce
or not i think you'll like it my goal is
to have some of these people fall in
love with my my hometown friends from
hickory i got a guy named john
john stamos's brother we call him marcus
stamos he just looks like him a little
bit
um after you watch it a couple times
you'll start
i think you'll get into it so check out
countryish
countryish.com
all right
thank you very much
as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryansickler.com go to
ryansickler.com for your tour tickets
come out and see me we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you